A group of well-armed Mobile Task Force members
entered the containment chamber, armed to the
teeth. Some faced the ground, droplets of sweat
dripping onto their visors, some wore Dr. Dan’s
infamous SCRAMBLE goggles, and one particularly
brave member of personnel wielded only a bag.
The room they were currently standing in was
perhaps the most dangerous place in the world.
Why?
Because it contained two terrifying
titans of the anomalous world: SCP-682,
the infinitely hateful Hard to Destroy Reptile,
and SCP-096, the Shy Guy, the ultimate mindless
killing machine. And if the very idea of having
them in the same place doesn’t feel risky enough,
this deadly duo had just spent 27 hours in
one of the most brutal brawls imaginable.
And incidentally, fights like this are exactly
why we’re here today. We cover a lot of SCPs on
this channel, and we’ve seen the way some of the
more dangerous anomalies out there can tear their
way through civilians and trained Foundation MTF
operatives with ease. But how do they fare against
monsters, maniacs, and reality benders their own
size? With the help of the SCP Explained audience,
we’re going to explore theoretical fights between
some of the anomalous world’s biggest badasses.
And who better to get this show on the road than
two of the most iconic and deadly monsters that
haunt the halls of a Foundation containment
site near you? The Hard to Destroy Reptile
and the Shy Guy are household names for
anyone familiar with the SCP Foundation,
and before we get to the gruesome results
of their first fight - and your theories
about how a potential rematch might play out
- let’s get to know the combat prowess of this
pair of nasty customers. What kind of damage
are they capable of taking and inflicting?
Spoiler Alert: It’s a hell of a lot.
In this corner, we have SCP-682: A monster
whose ability to survive seemingly anything
is only equaled by its terrible attitude toward
pretty much everyone and everything around it.
Though to be fair, you’d probably be a little
grumpy too if the SCP Foundation was constantly
trying to murder you in different ways
rather than just keeping you contained.
682’s basic offensive power set involves
impressive strength, speed, intelligence,
and the aid of its deadly fangs, claws,
and tail. However, 682 is considerably
stronger after it’s just survived and
regenerated from a termination attempt.
That’s because the true combat asset of 682
is and always has been its adaptability.
Specifically, if some kind of attack
brings 682 into a state of near-death
but doesn’t finish the job, 682 will
generally either develop a perfect defense
or counter-offensive for that attack or somehow
add a version of the attack to its own arsenal.
This has ranged from super-pressurized jets
of its own blood, dangerously radioactive
banana beams fired out of its mouth, and even
an incapacitating laugher blast gained from an
encounter with the adorable SCP-999.
It’s an absolute swiss army knife of
dangerous anomalous powers and abilities -
And if you need any further proof of that,
check out our multiple videos on all the ludicrous
failed attempts to kill this nightmare lizard.
And in this corner, we’ve got SCP-096, the
Shy Guy. While 682 is freakishly adaptable,
in most situations, SCP-096
is pretty much unstoppable.
This long, gangly creep will murder anyone
who sees even the tiniest glimpse of its face
with such ferocity that not even a trace of the
body will remain. It does this by entering what
many call its “Rage State”, activated by the
sudden immense distress of its face being seen.
When it enters this state, the SCP Foundation
has only one prerogative: Get themselves and
anyone else out of its way, because you will not
stop this thing until it’s killed its target.
All the SCP Foundation has ever been able to do is
wait until after the target has been obliterated,
and then come in to bag its head when it enters
its docile state. Almost nothing else has even
successfully slowed it down. While they
have been capable of damaging its flesh,
the monster’s skeleton seems to be utterly
indestructible, and its damaged flesh has proven
consistently able to grow back. The monster seems
to be immune to everything from pain to cold,
and moves at such a speed that it’s
pretty much impossible to escape for long.
So when you factor in an indestructible
body, immense strength, immense speed,
and an unstoppable urge to kill anyone who sees
its face, you’re looking at a formidable opponent.
It’s only natural that the Foundation would
want to use 096 in their 682 cross tests,
so what exactly happened when the Mobile Task
Force entered the room after their first epic
battle? What did they find inside
the chamber in the grisly aftermath?
SCP-096 lay crumpled in the corner, wheezing,
scarred, covered in its own blood. SCP-682 was
barely recognizable - SCP-096 had reduced
it to a quarter of its original size,
the rest having been utterly torn to shreds. Both
had narrowly survived the encounter, but it was
an epic battle neither of them would ever forget
- Though this was especially true for SCP-096.
You see, as we alluded to earlier, SCP-682
is used to taking a kicking at this point.
It hasn’t ever truly been
killed, but it’s been beaten,
eaten, burned, zapped, and smashed within an
inch of its life more times than you can count.
096, on the other hand, was not used to not
being able to utterly eliminate its prey.
While it’s impossible to speculate
what’s going on inside SCP-096’s mind,
all evidence points towards getting a draw in this
battle, seriously damaging SCP-096’s confidence.
Now, every time Foundation personnel tries
to bring 096 into 682’s containment chamber,
he begins crying and scratching at his own face.
Why? Is he scared of 682? Is he humiliated,
thinking of the fight he wasn’t able to win?
Or is the very idea of someone seeing his face,
and him not being able to immediately
kill them, just too unbearably stressful?
Seeing as the Shy Guy’s mouth is only good
for two things - and neither of them are
talking - we’ll never truly know. But either way,
it’s clear that 096 has no interest in a rematch…
...But what if that changed?
What if 096 realized that it
was wasting its potential.
It managed to get SCP-682 three-quarters of
the way to death last time, what could stop
it from getting that last quarter? Sure,
nothing has ever killed SCP-682 before,
but there’s a first time for everything, right?
Maybe 096 would have a Rocky-style training
montage, where he rebuilds his confidence and
becomes the underdog he was always meant to be.
He’d walk right up to that big, nasty reptile,
and give him the rematch of the century.
What would happen then?
Now, we give the floor to you, the loyal viewers
of SCP Explained. Here are some of your thoughts,
theories, and opinions on a potential
historic rematch between these two creeps.
Let’s get ready to rumble!
PinguWithAnAxe said, “If 682's adaptability
is based around his ability to develop
countermeasures to any damage inflicted
(or in the case of 173, a countermeasure
to the cause of said damage) I imagine 682
would turn his skin entirely reflective,
causing 096 to see his own face and the
feedback loop would break his mind.”
Interesting. Whether this would work is all
dependent on whether SCP-096 can actually see,
or if it is merely capable of psychically
intuiting when someone else sees its face.
If the latter is true, then this particular
adaptation wouldn’t do much good for SCP-682.
Random User said, “If this is after their first
cross test and they were forced to interact again,
they wouldn’t attempt to fight
each other. I feel like they’d
form a truce and take out
the researchers on-site.”
This would be one of the worst-case scenarios.
Whether even the SCP Foundation could handle
a simultaneous 682 and 096 breach without
bringing in Hammer Down is an open question.
Ramon Voncken said, “Simple, after the first
encounter, when 096 stopped attacking 682,
682 will grow eyes that filter
out 096s face the next time.”
Organic SCRAMBLE goggles. Dr. Dan
would be fuming with jealousy.
Koopsader said, “I really want
SCP-096 to win so I’m sending
him a blind personal trainer so he
can beat the snot out of SCP-682.”
This is exactly the kind of help SCP-096 needs.
He’s got the rage, endurance, and strength, with
a little help getting his form and technique in
order, he’d be an even more formidable opponent.
Kytoe Ryu said, “I'd like to imagine
096, after playing with 682 for so long,
would try to eat 682 in a vain attempt to kill
it, only to gain 682’s abilities, and vice versa.”
Either of these options would be
horrifying. SCP-096 with 682’s abilities,
or 682 with 096’s abilities, would likely
be a truly perfect killing machine.
Autumn said, “What If they just shared a
nice cold drink while playing Mario Kart?
I’m sure 096 would be the white
shy guy character in every race.”
Personally, we love this idea, and
we think SCP-682 would go for Bowser.
Ibraheem Temur said, “682 would win
eventually. It’s way more intelligent,
adaptive, and overall malicious
while 096 acts just on instinct.”
This is an undeniably good point. What 682
lacks in sheer savagery, it makes up for in
its ruthless, calculating intelligence.
Could this give it the edge over 096?
Monomoy Mukherjee said, “That fight
will be interesting because both of
them now know how they attack
and what their attacks are.”
Nice segue. Due to the relatively
mindless nature of 096,
as far as we’re aware, it’s probably
unable to learn from experience.
682, however, would have the advantage of
knowing how 096 operates in the second battle.
Devan Smith said, “As much as I'd
like to see how this would play out,
I imagine 096 can't manage more
than other SCP's have in the past.
Not to downplay him, but he might need some
extra friends to do a whole lot more damage.”
It’s undeniable that going in with tag
team partners would better 096’s chances
of taking the lizard down. However, due
to SCP-096’s shyness, and tendency to kill
everyone and everything that looks at him, he
doesn’t have many friends looking to volunteer.
Nyan Tails said, “096 will cry in the
corner while 682 starts attacking it
eventually it gets confused that 096
isn't fighting back after an hour and
begins to adapt to it and becomes docile forever.”
Look, while it’s unlikely that this would
happen, it’s certainly nice to imagine, isn’t it?
Adam Britton said, “Narratively it
needs to conclude with a reason to never
try it again. So I'm going to say that
682 will telepathically project the
image of 096 into the site staff
or the entire human pychospace.”
Yikes. This is a possibility
so terrifying - And honestly,
plausible - that it’s making us regret
wanting to see this rematch altogether.
Chaos Insurgency said, “I think 682 would just
think "For damn’s sake, just leave me alone!"
Given he’s been through more termination
attempts than SCP-5031 can count on its fingers,
who could blame him for
getting a little frustrated?
Michael Porter said, “I think that 682 and 096
would take each other to court for aggravated
assault against the other. Either one of them will
get sentenced to death and will unsurprisingly not
die or the 2 team up to kill the entire courtroom
and they walk out as a new serial killing team.”
The real question is what kind of lawyers
would represent a pair of murderous,
anomalous monsters in court. Better call Saul.
Ari Wertman said, “Maybe if we
try being nice to them for once,
we can offer them a cup of tea
and get them both a therapist.
682 will talk all his hate away and then
realize his wrongdoing and become an activist,
and 096 would become very confident about his
face and become a model. There problem solved.”
Hey, when people strive towards
self-improvement, we’re all winners.
But we don’t know if we can say the same for 682
and 096. Even if this rematch ever did happen,
perhaps it’d just be another draw - An
unstoppable force against an immovable object.
But other match-ups may be more clear-cut.
What kind of Vs battles would you like
to see us cover in the future? What SCPs
would you really love to see duke it out?
Let us know in the comments, and
keep an eye on the community posts,
in order to throw in your anomalous
two cents for our next Vs battle!
Now go check out “SCP-682 - Ways
SCP Foundation Tried to Kill Hard
To Destroy Reptile” and “SCP-096
Shy Guy ESCAPE - Incident 096-1-A
Containment Breach” for more of the scoop
on these two star anomalous combatants!